This Is 50 seconds for every 50 year old
in the world I need you to understand
something you have so much time I'm in
entrepreneur land and I meet with all
these kids show these kids show these
kids all these kids and and they're
taking advantage of the new world right
but they're young and they're raw and
they've got a lot of great and some of
them are great and they'll be all-time
great but what blows me away is how many
of you have decided that you're finished
that you're on the back end of your life
that you can't accomplish it that this
wasn't built for you I didn't grow up
with this either but I figured it
out you figured out how to drive you
figured out how to be a parent you
figured it all out and with the health
Trends and the way the world is now
you've got a long life in front of you
so instead of sitting in that job for
the next 10 years go do your thing
you've got plenty and plenty of time